the final moments of what began as a
routine traffic stop the suspected
gunman a white man in his 30s shot dead
by police outside a cinema complex in
Odessa Western Texas where there are
multiple scenes and multiple victims at
some point the subject stole a mail
truck ditched his car and there were
other victims after that this video
posted online showed terrified families
as gunfire rings out nearby according to
monitors the gun violence archive it's
the 270 ninth mass shooting in the US
this year it comes just weeks after a
white nationalist shot dead 22 people
and a shopping center in the Texan
border city of El Paso gun violence is a
hugely political issue in the United
States within minutes of the shooting
candidates vying to be the next
president weighed in with Democrat and
Texas native better o'rourke making a
call to action tweeting we need to end
this epidemic Texas is traditionally
supportive of the right to carry arms
and on Sunday new laws come into effect
allowing people to take guns to school
parking lots and houses of Prayer
to work with leaders in both parties in
the Congress take such steps that we can
address and confront this scourge the
House Judiciary Committee had planned to
discuss gun control legislation this
week but that's been put off because of
the approaching storm hurricane Dorian
Odessa Texas now on the list of cities
known for gun violence and like the
others thoughts and prayers are being
offered what many want though a concrete
plans for change
elixir Brian al-jazeera